all right let's go to courtney in
daytona beach courtney what is up
hi how are you i'm so good courtney how
are you
good i'm so excited to have this
opportunity to speak with you and
me with you go for it what's up
okay so i need advice on
how to tell my parents that i had a baby
that i placed for adoption
and the back story to that is in
december of 2018 i was only 19 years old
i was very unexpected i found out as i
was having him
and so we decided that the best the best
route would be
adoption and that has worked out
absolutely beautifully
i can't complain about that at all but
now i'm kind of stuck in a place where
i think i really need to tell them in
order to keep moving forward
but my boyfriend isn't as open with it
and so i don't want to really be too
disrespectful against like
his wishes on the topic so i'm really
like stuck
wow there's a lot there okay so number
one thank you for calling let's
unpack this a little bit so a couple
years ago you had a baby
you placed it for adoption and you carry
the baby
full term places to adoption and baby's
doing well are you still in contact with
the adoptive parents or is your baby i
have a
you know i have a great relationship i
talk to her probably once a week if
maybe two weeks but we have a very good
relationship wow how
remarkable and they're good folks good
parents and you feel wonderful about
your
baby being there yes i have my view on
it is
this was meant to happen that's just how
everything's worked out very well
on my side of it that's that's
incredible okay so
is this boyfriend you have the is that
the
father of this child or somebody new
okay so y'all are still together
yes how long has have you all been
together um
three years in december three years okay
and so why aren't you married yet why
don't you just say dude this is this is
the guy let's just call it
i don't know we've honestly talked about
it but
i don't know i don't know i think it
really has to do with me because i'm
like i'm tv young this
and that but i have a bunch of i guess
qualifications of what i think i need to
be before i could be married
is what it is name some of them for me i
honestly want
my debt paid off which i know is like
you can do it together but i
also i'm not even i'm only 20 now he's a
little bit older
i feel like you need a house first you
need to be in the position to buy a
house together
okay just little stuff like that which i
know isn't true but that's what i think
hinders it so those things are all real
but you've kind of knocked everything
out of order because you have those
three things and then you have a kid
right and so you went out of order there
um yeah so as a couple y'all have
experienced a lot of things that
most couples experience after
they've committed to one another for the
rest of their lives how did he feel
about this adoption
he kind of you know he was very
supportive and he was there for me and
he still has been but i think over time
it's been harder for him than it has
been for me like i've coped with it very
well
and he i don't think has like it's we
don't really talk about it it's kind of
uncomfortable to talk about with him
which it's like kind of makes me sad
because i find it to be such
a happy thing like if you know if it had
to happen take the time the joy in it
and kind of go with it i feel like for
him it's a little bit harder
how is he struggling what does harder
mean i
just he doesn't talk about it like i'll
get pictures printed out or i got like
in in preparation of telling my parents
i ordered a photo book and i was like
here you go that's one step closer and
he still hasn't looked at it and i think
it's just hard because he's
about he's a late
20s so i think it's for him it's more
like i should have been ready
i should have been at the age type of
thing yeah so he is probably
experiencing quite a bit of shame
i had a i had a child and
in my mid to late 20s and i wasn't quote
unquote man enough to take care of that
kid
i yeah i think that's exactly what it is
because he also doesn't
reach like he's we're all friendly with
the parents but he doesn't go out of his
way to like reach out to them
his thing is you know if they want to
talk to me they can send me a message
it's not like in a bad way but i think
it is he just doesn't like to
that sounds pretty mature i mean that
can't do yeah that sounds pretty
immature for somebody who
created a human right and again that
goes
that's the responsibility of hooking up
is
the result is you could have a human
life right and then you've got to be
able to deal with that
all right so yeah it sounds like he's
going through a lot here's my thought
here
um so he's how long did you say he's 28
yeah okay so i want to back out a 26
year old hooked up with an 18 year old
and y'all had a kid
and i don't want to minimize the
the magic love making experience that a
26 year old an 18 year old are going
through but y'all hooked up and you had
a kid
and you did a noble and remarkable thing
and you blessed a family with that
beautiful baby
and they're doing great and you are able
to see that for the blessing that it is
good for you when it comes to telling
your parents
you're not married to this dude you all
have been dating for a while you're not
married to this guy so i'm going to tell
you he didn't get a vote
and if this secret between you and your
family is hanging
there like a giant weight around your
neck
which i'm confident that it is it's my
opinion that
that secrets kill people they drown
people and i would recommend talking to
your folks
there's not going to be a cute way to do
this or a
um a you know like making a book or try
this isn't going to be a
fun beautiful conversation this is going
to be one of those conversations that
you
let your parents know ahead of time we
need to have a hard talk
and that we're going to have a hard
conversation and
i'm going to need you and mom like mom
and dad and y'all to be
direct and paying attention to me and
then we're gonna go have breakfast
somewhere
and just let them know i want you to
know they're gonna be devastated they're
gonna be heartbroken
not that there is a grandkid that they
don't know about that will be a thing
here's what they're going to be
devastated about
that their baby girl went through
something so hard and they weren't there
for them
they were there for you does that make
sense
yeah no i've spoken to some of my older
siblings about it and they said the same
thing
they're like they're not gonna be mad at
you because i was like are they gonna be
mad
and they're like no they're gonna be you
know probably disappointed or upset that
they didn't find out sooner yeah they're
gonna be disappointed that they didn't
walk with you through this journey right
it's a magical transformation and then
then the babies all the stuff right and
they're gonna probably say things like
well we would have helped and
now they're gonna deal with somebody
else raising in their mind their
grandkid
right and that their teenage daughter
had to make this heavy heavy decision
all on their own
but here's the thing it is what it is so
i want you to not go into this
conversation with any sort of fantasy
any sort of mythological
there's going to be confetti come down
everybody's going to hug and they're
going to
it's just going to be a hard
conversation gear yourself up for it but
the hard conversation is still the right
conversation
and it sounds like you're tired of this
secret
and i'm telling you right now is no
matter how hard this conversation goes
you're going to feel a burden lifted off
your heart in your soul
it's definitely hard i feel like i'm
living like two lives because i get
pictures i get updates and it's like i
yeah right now it's like you can't share
that with them and i find so much joy in
it so i feel like they would
in a way too to know that i i did make
the right choice because i have such
an involvement still and it's not like i
made this decision and then i never
heard about it again that's right um
would would your adoptive
parents are they open to your parents
visiting
or you're all just we've kind of
discussed it and she left
it the mom left it to if if
he ever asked about them okay he would
be the one to do it she wouldn't want to
push it on him
okay i think that's really wise and good
good for her yeah he looks like you
picked a wonderful family
so the challenge for your parents is
they're going to want to see the baby
and they're going to want to see
their likeness representing their
grandkids there's just gonna be a piece
of their heart out running around in the
universe that they can't see and hug and
touch
right and so just know that's gonna be
hard
but also know that it's again it's the
right conversation to have
and so i here here's the steps in order
number one i would
let them know ahead of time don't just
show up at their house one afternoon
drop a bomb on them
let them know hey we need to have a hard
conversation and
i'm gonna come to your house so we're
gonna do this or we're gonna go get
pancakes together and we're going to
have this hard conversation
you know what they're going to think
they're going to think that you're
pregnant now and they're going to think
that you need to have a quick shotgun
wedding with this older guy that they
may or may not like
they're not going to be expecting that
you already had a baby and the baby is
one and a half or two years old and
doing well with an adoptive family
so you're gonna surprise them understand
they're gonna be heartbroken they're
gonna they're gonna
cry and that doesn't mean what you did
is is not the right thing
and then be willing to be willing to
heal that relationship with your parents
they're going to feel like they let you
down they're going to feel like you let
them know it's just going to be messy
it's just going to be messy
and messy and hard doesn't mean it's the
wrong thing
you're going to have to grieve this with
your parents here's the deal your
parents had a picture in their head
of what the grandkid was gonna be like
the first grandkid
and they've imagined it they're gonna
imagine themselves of buying all this
shenanigans for this baby right and
coming over and
and they're gonna have to reframe their
picture
they're gonna have to grieve it they're
gonna have to grieve this
this this new world that they're in that
you're gonna just drop on them at a
denny's
at nine o'clock on some saturday morning
you're gonna have to grieve
a new relationship with your parents
you're also going to have to grieve a
transitioning relationship with this guy
you're 20 he's 28 he's almost got a
decade on you
at some point you're gonna have to
decide this is the guy for me or not
he's gonna have to deal with the grief
of his child um he's gonna have to deal
with the grief of
um i should have been there i should
have raised my own kid
and i didn't um and that doesn't mean
that was the wrong thing but he's gonna
have his own thoughts he's
in the more he hides from that stuff the
deeper that wounds gonna get the more
that infection's gonna fester and it's
just gonna
end up spraying all the people he loves
too so he's gonna have to do his own
work
and so i keep talking about the first
two calls here i've talked about grief
and i've talked about grief and i've
talked about grief
really quickly um let's talk about grief
for a second
kubler-ross came up with this model
years and years ago
back in the late 60s early 70s she wrote
this book on death and dying and it was
really a discussion this book was a
discussion
of the five stages of grief she came up
with and they are denial
anger bargaining depression and
acceptance
so when somebody dies in your life you
deny it then you get
angry you get pissed off and then you
start barging with
god you start bargaining with the people
around you i'll be nicer if
and then you go through this depression
you just get through in that black hole
of grief
that if anyone is if you've lost
somebody you know what i'm talking about
and then you get to the acceptance stage
where you start to rebloom you start to
regrow
and you just realize this is what this
is and we often think about
you know death that's the thing that we
grieve right
kubler-ross these stages were initially
designed for people who
weren't grieving the losses of loved
ones or broken relationships it was
written for it was designed for people
who were grieving their own impending
death
she was with people who were dying and
then in 2019 david kessler
who was who studied with her i think he
was one of her research assistants he
wrote
one of my top five most important books
of my life
he wrote it's called finding meaning to
stick
sixth stages of grief and we'll put that
in the show notes here
we'll put both these books in the show
notes but if you have to pick up one
book
over the next few months pick up finding
meaning by david kessler especially in
these times it's a remarkable book
on grief is so much bigger than
somebody's dying or you died grief is
about
any sort of what you thought was gonna
happen is not gonna happen
right you thought you were gonna be an
astronaut it didn't work out that way
you
thought you were gonna meet some
romantic prince and he turned out to be
an abusive jerk
you thought that my picture of my first
grandkid
is going to be this we're going to hold
this baby
and it's going to be an easy birth and
my daughter's going to be
healthy and she's going to the father of
this child is going to be this wonderful
guy
and he's going to be there and then all
of a sudden you find out that your first
grandkid
was adopted underneath you you didn't
know and it's somewhere else
all of those things are grief it's just
that the picture you thought was going
to be your tomorrow has changed
and the longer we go through life not
acknowledging that
the more it festers within us there
becomes a gap and we fill that gap with
all kinds of addictive behaviors
busyness numbing behaviors
drinking well all kinds of crazy things
we run around right
and so what kessler brings to the table
here is
after acceptance right after you just
make peace with it
that's not enough there's this next step
this sixth step
and that is what are you going to do as
a result of
right are you going to become an
advocate for adoptive families
are you going to be an advocate for
parents having great relationships with
their teenage kids
so that they feel safe to come home and
talk to you are you going to
become somebody who is really
involved in aa because you lost a loved
one to
alcoholism or drug abuse whatever the
thing is how are you going to make
meaning how are you going to transform
your heart and the hearts of those
around you
because you went through this right and
an important thing about these stages is
they're not linear
right sometimes people die and you get
angry
and then you deny it and then you go
into the black hole or somebody passes
away and you go into the black hole or
you just randomly get dumped
and whoosh you feel like you've just
been stuck under water
right eventually you begin to
breathe again if you've got people
walking alongside you eventually you get
to
exhale again the sun comes up
the buds that were broken off begin to
begin to bloom
the world turns green again and here's
the thing here's a great quote from this
this kessler book here's the here it is
when we are grieving we want to stay in
the harbor
it's a good place to be for a while it's
where we refuel rebuild
repair but in the same way ships are
meant to sail
we are meant to eventually leave our
safe harbor to take
the risk of loving again to find new
adventures
to live a life after loss and maybe
even to help another right this is what
finding meaning is
is about this is what stopping we
thought 2020 was going to be this thing
and this thing and this thing and this
thing
it's not i thought i was going to get to
have this awesome new job promotion
and and i'm not i'm homeschooling my kid
i've got a bandana on that i take off
just for this zoom meeting and then i
put it back on i'm
i've just got to grieve what i thought
was going to be so that i can come to
the present and deal with what's now
and then over time i'm going to accept
where i'm at i'm going to
sometimes bite down on my mouthpiece and
just go in swinging other times i'm
going to
let the things go that i can't control
and over time we're going to make
meaning
we're going to make meaning and we're
going to continue to live the story the
best way that we can
so thank you so so much for that call
courtney
i'll be thinking about you i would love
love
love courtney call me back after that
conversation with your folks
if all three of you want to call me back
i'd love to talk to your parents too i
want to hear how that conversation goes
i want to hear how you all
work together to make a plan for
tomorrow